plus there's of course there's david
bowie in it and there's his music
so that'll attract um also all the
teenagers and all the music lovers and
everything
i've brought you a gift not only was he
a genius he was a genius who had the
time to be kind it doesn't look that far
it's further than you think time is
short
it's just completely different than i
had imagined
i never imagined such grand sets i've
never worked on a film this
big everything is new which is quite
wonderful actually even just filming it
it's wonderful to see
all the puppets and all the effects well
as you can see not everything is full of
[Music]
delight
there are many other things that do
happen that she does realize to be
the labyrinth it is a lot like old fairy
tales but you've only seen them in your
mind
and to see it actually physically being
here and to be
inside it is something completely new
well it's obviously very different and
it's a whole
entire different world that that she's
never seen before that i've never seen
before
with different creatures which of course
when you're encountering something
completely new
it is sometimes very frightening when
you're not with people that you know
you're not with
other humans i move the stars for no one
[Music]
and you're sort of lost on your own in
this
in this big world and a lot of it is
frightening but then there are some
very beautiful parts and i do make some
nice friends
you have no power over me
i went into to rushes once i got to see
one part of it it was basically adults
there and they
they loved it plus there's of course
there's david bowie in it and there's
his music
so that'll attract um also all the
teenagers and all the music levels and
everything
yeah well that's one of the main reasons
that we chose david
it's something you can't quite put your
finger on it and at the same time it's
very powerful
and i think he has that he has that
range which is what we wanted from
from our armed villain he was wonderful
to work with and the music that he did
is just delightful
i mean it was just magical you know for
kids and i loved jim henson and david
bowie was so sweet to me
and it was great it was a really special
experience making it
[Music]
i have a lot of extraordinary memories
of him you know i think it's very
sad not only was he a genius he was a
genius who had the time to be kind
that's my experience of him
[Music]